former president barack obama turns 60
years old and celebrates in maskless
fashion we examine the numbers on who
wants to return to normal and the
vaccine mandates are coming i'm ben
shapiro this is the bench bureau show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
i protect my data with a vpn so should
you visit expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first your reminder again the
internet is not always anonymous you
think that things like incognito mode
protect you they do not sadly the big
tech monopoly has decided that they are
interested in monitoring all your data
selling all your data keeping track of
you passing it on to the government how
about this how about you reestablish the
anonymity you so richly deserve by
checking out expressvpn if you've ever
wondered how free to access tech giants
make all their money the answer is they
track your searches video history
everything you click on by building a
profile on you and then selling off your
sensitive data when you use the
expressvpn app on your computer or phone
you anonymize much of your online
presence by hiding your ip address that
makes your activity more difficult to
trace and sell to advertisers what's
more expressvpn encrypts 100 of your
network data to protect you from
eavesdroppers and cyber criminals what i
like most is how easy it is to use it
takes just one click to protect all of
your devices which is why expressvpn is
rated number one by both cnet and wired
revoke big text right to your data
secure your internet with the vpn i
trust for online protection visit
expressvpn.com pen that's
expressvpn.com to get three extra months
for free with my exclusive link go to
expressvpn.com
ben right now to learn more alrighty so
happy birthday to obama he's the only
person who gets to have a really big
birthday party now listen here's my
feeling about birthday parties or
parties of any sort at this point it's a
free country do what you want
i myself would be happy to have a
birthday party for my wife for any of my
relatives masculists as you know i don't
care my feeling at this point is that
every adult in the united states every
person in the united states above the
age of 12 has had the ability to get the
vaccine once you've had the vaccine your
chances of dying from cova 19 drop down
to very close to zero if you get a
breakthrough of the delta variant and
you're vaccinated the high likelihood is
that you're going to end up with a mild
cold and thus if
there's a party and somebody shows up
unvaccinated and that person gets
infected by a vaccinated person that one
is on them so on a pure principled level
i don't care whether barack obama has a
masculist party but
but the entire democratic infrastructure
has decided
that for the sake of being a good
american you must mask up you must you
know if you're a vaccinated person you
must put on that mask to protect
everybody else if you're a good
patriotic american you would not hold a
large party for your own 60th birthday
and you certainly wouldn't fly in your
friends like john kerry
to come in maskless on a private jet in
the middle of global warming which by
the way did happen john kerry did take a
private jet to barack obama's party and
uh and then everybody at the party took
off the masks and uh one of the djs
there made the unfortunate error of
actually tweeting out the photos and
then had to delete all the photos some
of the footage was out there already
however and and things were
unfortunately leaked to the public i say
unfortunately even though it's actually
quite fortunate because i think it's
quite important that the american people
know that the elites who tell you that
you need to mask up the elites who tell
you that life can never go back to
normal these same elites do not hold
themselves to the same standard at all
at all and this has always been the case
with the left when it comes to the left
the people at the top of the echelon are
not interested in abiding by the rules
they promulgate for everybody else the
people at the top of the elite those the
elitists in our society the people in
hollywood and they will abide by the
basic rules of success in the united
states while ensuring ensuring that
everybody else doesn't and this is
basically charles murray's book coming
apart he talks about the fact that you
have very liberal elites living off of
sunset boulevard who promulgate social
standards they themselves do not hold by
and so they become rich and they do
really well and many of them are married
and many of them stay married and then
they promulgate values that everybody
else holds by and those people take
those standards seriously and they wreck
their lives well the same thing holds
true when it comes to things for example
like whether to have a maskless birthday
party you the peasant are not supposed
to have a maskless birthday party in
fact one of our writers over at daily
wire rides vedra he tweeted out recently
that his grandfather just died alone in
the hospital of covid because there had
been all of these revised protocols that
suggested you couldn't go in and visit a
dying loved one who had coveted whether
you were vaccinated or whether you were
not vaccinated because after all you
might spread it to somebody and so they
die so people are dying alone in the
hospitals again meanwhile barack obama
is having a party so this is where i
start to get up tight not when somebody
has a party i don't care i live in
florida a lot of people having parties
what i care about is if you promulgate a
standard where no one else is supposed
to have a party just like nobody else is
supposed to take a private jet except
for john kerry just like nobody else is
supposed to
hold by sort of traditional moral
standards apparently except for many of
the people in hollywood who actually
counter-intuitively do
it's the same thing here everybody else
is supposed to mask up and watch grandma
die alone but barack obama gets to have
himself the big party with john legend
singing at the party and everybody
partying without the masks here's a
little bit of the footage
you can see in the background barack
obama partying on stage
there he is going at it
really enjoying himself hugging people
on stage
again this isn't an indoor scenario
i was reliably informed by the cdc by
rachelle wolenski by our most trusted
physicians by dr anthony fauci you
shouldn't be having events like this i
was told and i was told by all the
democratic higher-ups in fact barack
obama fibbed and he said he was going to
cancel the party or at least wildly
downgrade the size and scope of the
party and then of course he just quietly
re-upped the party and then all this
information
started emerging again so you might
think that at this point the media would
be somewhat critical of this i mean
after all barack obama is a pretty
important person he's the former
president of the united states and we've
been informed that former presidents of
the united states are not just important
they are the most important people when
donald trump puts out a statement on his
email list it immediately rockets around
the internet because it's so damned
important when barack obama has a
masculist birthday party you might
assume that the media would be like well
that's that's odd right i mean that's
worthy of coverage well you would be
wrong instead you'd have the cnn white
house correspondent saying it's
different guys it's different because
these are the sophisticated people you
are a rube you're a person who has a
nine-to-five job who still has to go to
work you're not somebody who became
president of the united states and then
made just a butt load of money after
having been president of the united
states by being a prominent politician
you go you like have a regular job and
you need to go to work but that's the
problem you you're the problem you
peasant you but barack obama is not a
peasant and the people at his parties
they are not the peasants right the the
peasants have a very different standard
than the than the lords and ladies
and non-specified and and
and royalty of unspecified gender who
attend barack obama's birthday party
here's the cnn white house correspondent
noting that this is it's a different
thing when barack obama does it then
when you do it get a party in your own
home for your kid's birthday
that was bad but barack obama he's
turning 60 and let me just tell you that
dude deserves a big birthday party
other people said you know this is
really being overblown
they're following all the safety
precautions people are going to sporting
events that are bigger than this this is
going to be safe this is a sophisticated
vaccinated crowd and and this is just
about optics it's not about safety by
sophisticated and vaccinated what they
mean sophisticated is code for very
wealthy and democrats that's what
sophisticated means in white house
correspondent for cnn language that's
what that means okay now this has a
pretty predictable effect when all the
elites in a particular society decide
that everybody is supposed to live one
way and they are supposed to live
another
this creates wild institutional distrust
but it also
creates a standard
where
politicians are incentivized to pursue
some of the dumbest policies ever so
when the media and the democratic
establishment say over and over and over
again that masking is going to be the
solution to the pandemic when asking
pretty obviously is not vaccination is
the obvious solution to the pandemic and
at this point the solution to the
pandemic is let everybody live their own
life and then bear the consequences of
their own decision-making which means
that the government really has very
little public policy role at this point
at all but it has bled down to the
american people and this is why this is
a story because barack obama and the
rest of the democratic party and joe
biden and dr anthony fauci and all the
various members of the democratic
establishment the lori lightfoots of the
world who said you couldn't get a
haircut but she needed her hair done
that was a very important thing or nancy
pelosi who said that you couldn't get a
haircut masculist but she definitely
could
or mayor muriel bowser who is who she
should listen she had to have a picture
masculist with dave chappelle like while
everybody else was masking up it was
super duper important
you the regular people are supposed to
change your life not just for now
forever and they've changed what the
standard is supposed to be forever
they've set up this incentive structure
and this is what pisses me off you
convinced a huge number of americans to
believe in things that are not reality
and not related to reality you're
scaring the hell out of people based on
bad data it's one thing to scare the
hell out of the unvaccinated and say to
them that you have a much higher chance
of dying from cover 19 than the
vaccinated that's true i mean now let's
be real about this the the rate of death
among young unvaccinated americans
remains
very low i mean compared to any other
disease like smallpox or any global
pandemic that people have considered a
mass killer in the past the grand total
number of americans under the age of 30
or between the ages of 20 and 30 who
have died in the united states is still
just a couple of thousand people i think
it's like 2 500 2600 people according to
the cdc as of last week
but you do have a much better chance of
dying
if you're unvaccinated then if you're
vaccinated for sure for sure okay but
they're not just restricting their crazy
standards to the unvaccinated they're
extending it to the vaccinated they're
basically saying you're supposed to be
scared in perpetuity and you can see in
school you can see in the new polling
statistics how this works out so
according to the washington post
two-thirds of americans now say that
once covet passes they plan to put on
masks when sick and wear comfortable
clothes more often than before according
to a washington post char school poll
that points to enduring cultural shifts
the public health crisis may bring about
when it comes to crowded places the
nationwide survey finds that more than 4
in ten us adults intend to wear masks in
such circumstances after the pandemic
that includes more than half of women
compared with one in three men
okay i will venture to say that this is
bad
because what we are teaching americans
is that
living life in a normal way like seeing
the faces of the people around you is
either of no matter at all which i don't
think is correct or two that you're just
supposed to mitigate all risk to the
most extreme extent humanly possible
even if the data don't support it
remember until last march if you asked
anthony fauci whether you should mask up
for for example the flu if there should
be mass masking for the flu anthony
factor would have said no and i'd be
curious to find out whether anthony
fauci has changed his opinion
if anthony fauci thinks that during a
normal flu season we should all mask up
now
whether this is now a broad-based change
with regard to masking or whether it is
covet specific
whether if you have a cold we're now
encouraging everybody during cold and
flu season to mask and what exactly is
the standard here because it seems like
the standard has changed pretty wildly
among us adults of all ages majorities
expect that they're going to be outdoors
more often which is very nice but it's
the masking that really is kind of
fanned
is kind of fascinating
so apparently 67 percent of americans
now say they plan to wear masks when
they are sick
which by the way if you apply that to
children
your children will never go to school
again okay kids are just little petri
dishes
apparently
43 of americans say long term and they
plan to wear max in crowded places like
forever
also there's a pretty wide partisan gap
here
and this is the this is the part that i
think is really telling who has returned
to a normal life who's returned to
normal life so as you imagine
republicans basically have returned to
normal life at this point independents
have largely returned to normal life
although they're and they're moving more
in that direction and democrats just
don't want to return to normal life
apparently ever so here's the partisan
breakdown on that according to this
brand new poll from the washington post
the question is how much have you
returned to your normal pre-coronavirus
life if you're not fully returned when
do you expect to be able to fully return
to your normal pre-coronavirus life only
15 percent of democrats say they are
fully returned to normal which is insane
given the fact that a huge percentage of
democrats are fully vaccinated which
means they are now at exorbitantly low
risk of dying of covet
48 of republicans so three times that
number say they are fully returned to
normal
and about twice the number of democrats
who are in independence 28 percent of
independence twice the number of
democrats say that they have fully
returned to normal
furthermore when it comes to
are you going to return to normal in the
next three months only 20 of democrats
say they are going to return to normal
in the next three months
in the next month to three months
22 percent of republicans say they will
so if you aggregate that what that means
is that about 35 percent of democrats
say they have fully returned to normal
or they expect to do so within the next
few months
fully 70 percent of republicans say
either they are fully back to normal or
they intend to in the next few months
and some 52 percent of independents say
that they either have fully returned
normal or they expect to in the next few
months which means
that the democrats are preaching
something and and accepting something
that is not going to be the long-term
answer here
right that partisan breakdown is not
even abided by by their own elites
okay the the criticism it really is kind
of incredible the criticism that has
been leveled for example
against the the
obama birthday party is extremely
minimal the amount of media attention
that has been paid to lori lightfoot
presiding over lollapalooza in chicago
and by the way if you think that this
idiotic notion that all these people
crowded extremely close together waving
vaccine cards as they walk in somehow
kept everybody safe over there that's
nuts that really is crazy number one if
you think that was a serious vaccine car
check you're wrong number two we now
have been told that vaccinated people
can pass to each other and to the
unvaccinated
but that's not stopping anthony fauci
from having some very strong words again
it is only directed at politics it is
only directed to politics the bad ones
it's a moral thing this is why the obama
birthday party matters it is no longer
about the science it is no longer about
the vectors of transmission it is no
longer about even the morality of who is
responsible for getting coveted and
whether they ought to take
responsibility for themselves now the
answer is if you do not perform the
pagan rituals that we have prescribed
for you then you are bad and if you do
perform those pagan rituals that we have
prescribed for you you are good and
here's the thing even if you don't
perform the pagan rituals but you say
that the pagan rituals are good then we
leave you alone so if barack obama has a
birthday party violating all of these
strictures that's okay he preaches the
strictures
but you know it's if lori lightfoot has
lollapalooza violating all the
structures but she's in favor of the
strictures she's fine you know who's
really bad though the sturgis motorcycle
rally so here's anthony fauci very very
concerned about the sturgis motorcycle
rally uh over in iowa
or south dakota rather
well i'm very concerned chuck that we're
going to see another surge related to
that rally i mean to me it's it's it's
understandable that people want to do
the kinds of things they want to do they
want their freedom to do that but there
comes a time when you're dealing with a
public health crisis that could involve
you your family and everyone else that
something supersedes that need to do
exactly what you want to do
again it's the selectivity of the
criticism that is really off-putting
here and really demonstrative of if you
worship the system then you can do
whatever you want you don't have to
abide by the rules it's the worship that
matters
it's the it's the mirroring the
sentiments of the most important that
matters more than anything else okay
we're gonna get to the latest arguments
in favor of masking kids and and locking
everything down in just one moment first
let us talk about the fact that if you
are a responsible adult you need to make
sure that you have the insurance you
need that includes home insurance and
many states home insurance is mandatory
policy genius makes it easy to compare
home and auto insurance in one place
they can help you find home and auto
coverage similar to what you have right
now but at a lower price they saved
customers an average of one thousand two
hundred fifty dollars per year over what
they were paying for home and auto
insurance they save new customers an
average of 435 bucks per year on auto
insurance
in fact they've saved new customers an
average of 350 bucks per year on home
insurance as well their team will handle
the paperwork set up your new policy
switch over your current one getting
started super simple first head on over
to policygenius.com shapiro home answer
a few quick questions about yourself and
your property and then policy genius
takes it from there they'll compare
rates from america's top insurers from
progressive to allstate to find your
lowest quotes the policy genius team can
look for ways to save you more including
bundling your home and auto policies
head on over to policygenius.com
shapiro home to get started right now
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it's nice and very very important to get
it right head on over to
policygenius.com
shapirohome and get started doing the
responsible thing right this very
instant okay so
putting aside the partisanship
the push right now is pretty hard from
the left and the public health
establishment in favor of things like
vaccine mandates and again i think that
this is coming from a a place that
doesn't make a whole hell of a lot of
logical sense so dr anthony fouch is
leading the way here of course he says
that you know we can't just act like
nothing is going on okay nobody's acting
like nothing is going on you may have
noticed that the vaccination rates have
gone up you may also have noticed that
republican governors are very much in
favor of people getting vaccinated and
ron desantis who's being ripped up and
down in florida will get some more on
desantis in just a second
his rate of vaccinating the elderly like
above people above the age of 65 is
actually higher than virtually all of
the blue states
so
what does he mean
before we act like nothing is going on
like we're acting like something is
going on but that doesn't mean you can
lock down everybody's freedom but
anthony fauci and the left have set up
the standard again the standard is zero
coded they won't admit to you that
that's what the standard is now what
they're aiming for here is zero covered
but that's what they're aiming for
they're aiming for zero covet they don't
care whether you actually follow the
rules so long as you say that they are
correct
for
pushing forward and popularizing their
foolish rules so here's anthony fauci
saying you know we have to get the
pandemic under control now here's the
thing
no one has the pandemic under control i
don't know what he's talking about this
notion that if you just mask everybody
up that's magically going to fix the
pandemic is belied by the fact that
right now australia is completely locked
down and has record transmissions
okay direct from australia today quote
this is reuters
australia saw a record daily number of
new coronavirus cases this past saturday
with the country's most popular states
of new south wales victoria and
queensland recording a total of 361
cases of the highly infectious delta
variant with about 15 million people or
of australia population under a strict
lockdown the country also reported five
coveted related deaths one of the
highest this year
new south wales suffered its worst
pandemic day reporting 319 new locally
acquired coveted 19 cases so
they're not doing like those numbers are
really low because they've decided to
lock everybody in their house but
they're still seeing higher numbers
in israel israel is like fully locked
down at this point
israel is giving people booster shots
they still saw about 3 900 new cases of
novel coronavirus reported in israel on
friday the number of patients in severe
condition spiked to 324 on saturday the
health ministry announced saturday night
of the patients hospitalized some 49 run
ventilators the death toll rose to
6535 on saturday night
okay so again israel is seeing a spike
everywhere is seeing a spike
this this bizarre notion that anthony
fauci knows how to get if he's known how
to get this under control i would love
to hear how anthony fauci has gotten
this under control at any point during
the pandemic like seriously at any point
like a point not many points one point
would be excellent here's anthony fauci
saying he can get the pandemic under
control by apparently yelling at
republicans by the way quick note you'll
notice they're yelling a lot about
florida they're not saying a damn word
about louisiana why
why why aren't they saying louisiana has
a worse spike than florida right now in
terms of percentage increase why is
louisiana not being mentioned
what party is the governor again
democrat here's anthony fauci
let's get this pandemic under control
before we start acting like nothing is
going on i mean something bad is going
on i mean we've got to realize that
nobody is saying nothing bad is going on
all we're saying is that you cannot
force everybody who's followed all the
rules and vaccinated and done all the
right things to stay in their house and
lock down and mask up you can't do that
it is none of your damn business what
the vaccinated do at this point and as
far as the unvaccinated it is still a
free country and if they wish to put
themselves at risk that is now their
business at a certain point you have to
let adults actually be adults
it's kind of crazy i mean you want to
talk about the paternalism of the
federal government at this point this is
the paternalism of the federal
government the nih director francis
collins he's going even further he says
let's just do vaccine mandates let's
force people to get the vaccine
for me as a non-political person as a
physician as a scientist the compelling
case for vaccines for everybody is
right there in front of you just look at
the data
and certainly i celebrate when i see
businesses deciding that they're going
to mandate that for their employees and
as a person who runs the national
institutes of health with 45 000
employees and contractors i am glad to
see the president insisting that we go
forward requiring vaccinations or if
people are unwilling to do that then
regular testing at least once or twice a
week which will be very inconvenient
okay they're not just stopping with
vaccine mandates for adults they're also
going to start pushing this for kids
we'll get to that in just one second
first let us talk about a great way to
preserve your family memories legacy box
it's an affordable way to have the
priceless moments from your aging home
movies and photos safely stored in a
format you can access and share whenever
you want imagine a lifetime of memories
right in your pocket even better legacy
boxes offering 50 off this very week
with legacy box you can reclaim all the
priceless footage you haven't been able
to see in years the service couldn't be
simpler use their kit to safely send the
moments you want preserved their team
will create a digital archive by hand
then you'll receive your new copies
stored on the cloud thumb drive or dvd
along with all of the original media you
sent them with their tracking system you
can monitor every step of the process so
you always know your originals are being
taken care of legacy box has helped over
1 million families restore and protect
their most cherished memories once you
have these digital versions you can
relax knowing they will be secure for
generations order in minutes enjoy
forever i did this for my parents it is
a wonderful magical gift because now
they can actually look back on their
family memories they're not buried in
videotapes they're not buried in film
reels they've got it all available right
now visit legacybox.com shapiro take
advantage of this limited time offer for
50 off discover the magic of bringing
your past back into view anytime
anywhere take advantage of this
exclusive offer today then use their kit
whenever you are ready that's
legacybox.com shapiro save 50 off
legacybox.com
shapiro alrighty so it is not merely
that you've got nih director francis
collins pushing for vaccine mandates and
businesses kicking people out if they're
not vaccinated which by the way results
in precisely the opposite of what it
seeks to do if you kick everybody
unvaccinated out of a business where
most of the people are vaccinated the
unvaccinated go and hang out together
and then you know what they do they
spread the virus really really really
easily okay but randy weingarten and
this is by the way is the most cynical
move it's perfectly obvious what she's
doing the american federation of
teachers randy weingarten who spent the
last year basically leveraging
governments into not forcing teachers to
go back to work and now she's been
trying to set up all of these roadblocks
he's just having to go back to work now
she says no no i'm very much in favor of
a vaccine mandates for teachers i think
maybe we should do that after all here's
randy weingarten
i want to be very careful that we have
to honor those religious exemptions um
but you know there there's ways of which
you can do accommodations in all sorts
of different ways which is part of the
reason you have to work together
on these um on these vaccine policies i
thought what joe biden did in terms of
the federal government of saying vaccine
and test or test was important and we
are supporting that i thought what bill
de blasio did was very important as well
okay so she says by the way that she now
wants the teachers to be forced to be
vaccinated she said i think the
circumstances have changed and that
vaccination is a community
responsibility and it weighs really
heavily on me that kids under 12 can't
get vaccinated
okay well how's that going to result
what is the clever move that she's
making here she understands a lot of
places are not going to force the
teachers to get vaccinated and so she's
going to say if you don't force the
teachers to get vaccinated legally
speaking they can't come back to school
right that is the little game that randy
weingarten is playing right here but
this has become again a democratic
talking point there's a democrat named
representative espiot who uh who was
pushing over the weekend he's from
illinois and uh and he was pushing the
idea that the federal government is
going to have to step in and on a
federal level sorry it's adreno espiona
from new york's 13th district he says
that the feds are going to have to
mandate masks in schools
and so people that are on that are not
vaccinated
are prolonging this pandemic we are
feeding the virus when we don't
vaccinate or we don't wear a mask and so
these are particularly uh in schools
with the children going back now in
september how could we not think of
making sure that our kids are protected
that they all have to wear a mask in
school uh certainly this is a very
practical and lifestyle in my opinion a
life-saving measure so the federal
government at some point will have to
step in and for uh stringent uh policies
that will protect everyone so much fun
guys so we went from states and
localities are going to do it too if a
state resists now the federal government
is going to this you see how all of this
is getting centralized up at the top
level and by the way in in variance with
the data so jen saki well this is kind
of an amazing thing so michael michael
osterholm right he's an advisor to he's
a coveted advisor to the biden
administration oscar holm and last week
we played a clip of him on national tv
pointing out that not all masks are
equivalent and that cloth masks in his
opinion do very little to actually
stop or the spread of covet 19
via the delta variant the reason being
the viral load of the delta variant is
significantly larger like a thousand
times larger than the alpha variant than
alpha so if that's the case cloth ain't
doing much so he's like well maybe
there's some other types of mass that
would work better
oster holm's comment i i'm not kidding
you he's an advisor to the body
administration apparently they were
taken off youtube
apparently social media is now in the
business of censoring advisors to the
biden administration if they do not
mirror
the party line with regard to the
efficacy of masking which is like that's
wild i mean that's crazy and then jen
saki decided she'd go to war with
osterhome now between ostrohome and sake
i think ostrohome knows more but
hirosaki saying well you know some
experts think that these cloth masks
definitely are going to
are going to the spread of kobe
19 via the delta variant oh well if jen
saki says so then the science is settled
apparently
let me first say that osterhome is not
an advisor to the president to the
administration to the white house he
doesn't work here he's a private citizen
and a medical a public health expert but
a lot of public health experts are out
there speaking and good for them i will
say that we are going to continue to
rely on the advice of medical experts in
the federal government on what kind of
masks we all should wear what kind of
masks kids should wear and if they
change that advice then the department
of education will be working with
schools to make sure that's implemented
as a mitigation measure yeah by the way
ostrohome
was a member of president-elect biden's
covenant advisory board so when she says
he doesn't work with biden she means
like right now not that he hasn't worked
with biden in the past which he has
so i guess now you can have him kicked
off of youtube then he was an advisor
now he lost all of his legitimacy the
minute that he was no longer connected
with joe biden marty mccarry has a good
piece over at the wall street journal
about whether kids should be masked he
says do masks reduce cover transmission
in children believe it or not we could
find only a single retrospective study
on the question his results were
inconclusive yet two weeks ago the cdc
sternly decreed that 56 million u.s
children and adolescents vaccinated or
not should cover their faces regardless
of the prevalence of infection in their
community authorities in many places
took the cue to impose mandates in
schools and elsewhere on the theory that
masks can't do any harm that isn't true
some children are fine wearing a mask
others struggle those who have myopia
can have difficulty seeing because the
mask fogs their glasses masks can cause
severe acne and other skin problems the
discomfort of a mass distracts some
children from learning by increasing
airway resistance during exhalation
masks can lead to increased levels of
carbon dioxide in the blood masks can be
vectors for pathogens if they become
moist or are used for too long by the
way none of this is particularly
controversial like the who has said this
okay the possible psychological harm of
widespread masking is an even greater
worry facial expressions are integral to
human connection particularly for young
children says marty mccary what about
the risk of covid which mass mandates
are intended to ameliorate the cdc
reports that for the week of july 31st
the rate of hospitalization with covet
for children 5-17 was 0.5 per million
per million which would amount to
roughly 25 patients
and the cdc says not all these kids were
in the hospital for covid viral testing
and admission is routine so a lot of
these kids were actually put in the
hospital for not covid but they had
taken a test showing they had covered
and so they're covered positive kids
children who do develop coveted symptoms
are at minimal risk of long covet
according to a lancet study published
august 3rd almost all children had
symptom resolution by 8 weeks providing
reassurance about long-term outcomes
children have been known to transmit
covets as mccary but far less often than
adults do
the cdc's mass decrees are perversely
permissive as well as needlessly strict
cloth masks aren't nearly as effective
as n95s but the cdc ignores the
distinction
we've been encouraging americans to wear
masks since the beginning of the
pandemic but special attention should be
paid to the many children who struggle
with masks
this is correct
any child who wants to wear a mask
should be free to do so but forcing them
to make personal health and
developmental sacrifices for the sake of
adults who refuse to get immunized is
abusive
okay but the abuse is the point it
really is the the goal here is you will
abide you will abide by we will scare
the hell out of you to the point where
you will mask up your kid and you will
love it
and if you and if you don't want to mess
up your kid it's because obviously you
don't take coveted seriously you're a
covet denier in the same way that the
left now claims that even if you agree
with all of the ipcc assessments about
climate change as long as you're not in
favor of aoc's new deal this means
you're a climate denier they're now
doing the same crap with covid
you you can point out all the stats you
can agree with this is the level of
deadliness you can agree with the
efficacy of vaccines you can even talk
about whether masks are helpful or
harmful depending on the circumstances
and what kind of masks you can do all of
those things but as long as you are not
mirroring what the left wants you to
mirror you're the bad guy and if you do
mirror what they want you to mirror you
can do whatever the hell you want you
can have a 60th birthday party with all
your friends they're massless so long as
you mirror whatever their garbage idea
of the day is
it really is amazing
it's it is it is not at all about what
is best policy
it is mostly about just who you yell at
and of course right now the person they
all want to yell at is uh is governor
ron desantis of florida so you recall
that last week the president of the
united states joe biden attacked ron
desantis and said it was just tara
rhonda's he couldn't believe ron
desantis was getting in the way of
school mass mandates
now ron desantis didn't say that kids
aren't allowed to put on a mask in
school
parents can buy kids in 1995 or a can 95
if they're really that concerned what he
said is that kids cannot be mandated to
wear a mask in school
and so that prompted biden to suggest
that desantis was sort of a cheerleader
for covid spread which is nuts again the
evidence that masked mandates have done
a damn bit of good anywhere on earth not
masking mask mandates they've done a bit
of good anywhere on earth is completely
missing there's no evidence for this
okay so desantis cracked back at biden
over the weekend he says you know so so
then
by then desantis slammed biden back and
then biden said governor who as they had
never heard of desantis which prompted
desantis to smack him pretty pretty hard
here
do you have a comment about the comment
that president biden made recently
well uh
i guess i'm not surprised that biden
doesn't remember me
i guess the question is what else has he
forgotten
biden's forgotten about the crisis at
our southern border i can tell you that
uh biden is forgotten about the
inflation that's biting the budgets of
families all throughout our country uh
biden has forgotten about the
demonstrators who are fighting for
freedom down in cuba and biden's even
forgotten about the constitution itself
as we saw with what he did with this
moratorium but resistance is bad you see
forget about the stats desantis is bad
it doesn't matter that florida continues
to rank near the middle of the pack in
terms of deaths per million
outperforming all of democrats favorite
states
with the second oldest population in
america it doesn't matter that the r
on florida's coveted spread is down
pretty significantly over the last
couple of weeks and which means that the
cases are going to peak pretty soon and
they're they're already starting to have
a lower rate of increase than they had
even a week ago or a week or two weeks
ago none of that matters desantis is the
bad guy as the cnn medical analyst
decided desantis is
is the problem obviously
right so don't get your medical advice
from the governor of florida first of
all there's no 1918 flu uh floating
around
there are a number of tools that a chief
executive has so a chief executive can
allow localities to mask up
their population they can certainly
allow school districts to mask up kids
who first of all
many of whom cannot be vaccinated now
and protect them he has prevented that a
uh chief executive of the state can
allow
vaccine mandates from businesses he is
preventing that
okay so again the the idea that they
have they know how to get this under
control it's just people won't listen
it's the children who are wrong you
never had any idea how to keep this
under control you failed you continue to
fail the only thing that keeps this
under control is the vaccines which were
created by the people you hate most over
in big pharma and the trump
administration
end of story the only thing that has
gotten this pandemic under control is
that as we saw in january when there
were no vaccines there was a huge wave
and a crapload of people died
and
again
by the way
this particular doctor happens to be
wrong according to history.com and he he
cites the the 1918 flu sans has said
that there are still variants of that
walking around quote history.com direct
descendants of the 1918 flu combined
with bird flu or swine flu to create
powerful new pandemic strains which is
exactly what happened in 1957 1968 and
2009 those later flu outbreaks all
created in part by the 1918 virus
claimed millions of additional lives
earning the 1918 flu the odious title of
the mother of all pandemics so whoops
turns out the cnn medical analyst on cnn
as per cnn's usual rule doesn't know
particularly what he's talking about
already coming up
we'll get to the latest in cuomo world
will andrew cuomo survive his bout with
grabbing ass we'll get that in just one
moment first let's talk for a second
about sending your mail so the reality
is you don't need to go down to the post
office post office is great why would
you want to wait in line it's annoying
instead why not head on over to
stamps.com you can skip trips to the
post office and save on postage you can
ship and mail anytime anywhere right
from your computer send letters ship
packages pay less a lot less with
discounted rates from usps and ups
stamps.com saves businesses thousands of
hours and tons of money every single
year
here at daily wire we've used stamps.com
since 2017 no more wasting our time
stamps.com brings the same us postal and
ups shipping services directly to your
computer they make it easy for small
businesses to mail and ship without
needing to take a trip to the post
office print official us postage and
shipping labels 24 7 without having to
leave your desk or buy any fancy
equipment all you need is your computer
and a standard printer once your mail is
ready just schedule a pickup or drop it
off it is indeed that simple stamps.com
it's a no-brainer which is why we have
been using it here for years on end and
they're offering you deals you can't get
anywhere else like 40 off usps 66 off
ups shipping rates that's pretty great
with their switch and save feature you
can quickly compare carriers find the
best rates every single time stop
wasting time going to the post office go
to stamps.com instead there's no risk
with my promo code shapiro you get a
special offer it includes a four-week
trial plus free postage and digital
scale no long-term commitments or
contracts just go to stamps.com click on
the microphone at the top of the
homepage type in shapiro that is
stamps.com promo code shapirostamps.com
never go to the post office again
already we'll get to andrew cuomo and
we'll
analyze the the growing drama in new
york first as you may have noticed
we are living in a very authoritarian
moment in which the federal government
is seeking to assume power over pretty
much everything from voting procedures
in the state to whether your child needs
to wear a mask at school and joe biden
just didn't care about the constitution
anymore plus all of the major
institutions have swung behind all of
the centralization of power in the
federal government and the woke agenda
this is my book my book is called the
authoritarian moment it is an important
book it is a vital read and you can get
it right now is number two on the new
york times bestseller list go get your
copy now leave a five star review help
get my book to number one on that
bestseller list it is now available at
amazon barnes noble any other major
bookseller the authoritarian moment it's
not just about how things got this bad
is about how to fix it it's really
important go check it out right now the
authoritarian moment i'm really proud of
the book i think it's a vital read check
it out yourself if there is one person
who's always trending for her
controversial and thought-provoking
takes i know like beside me it's it's
candace owens and now you have a chance
to meet her you can hear her drop her
truth bombs live by sitting in her
studio audience
if you sign up now as a daily wire
member with code vip you'll get 25 off
your new membership and be automatically
entered for a chance to win a trip for
two to the daily weather studios in
nashville not only will you be meeting
candace you'll also be getting an inside
look at her studio to get front row
seats to watch her destroy the left's
insidious ideology on her talk show
candace it's a great time on candace's
set this isn't an opportunity i would
pass up were iu so if you're in the mood
for a trip to nashville full of leftist
takedowns go enter now to win two vip
tickets to a kansas vip pass right now
at dailywire.com
subscribe using code vip get 25 off so
that's a great deal 25 off code vip plus
a chance to win tickets to candace's
show you're listening to the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
alrighty meanwhile in new york remember
that you remember that governor andrew
cuomo he's the one i really love right
he was the good governor he was desantis
is the bad governor cuomo was the best
governor i mean he won an emmy for
goodness sake he wrote an entire book
about leadership during covet 19 while
killing all the olds and then covering
it up well now he's in a bit of trouble
melissa de rosa a fixture next to
governor andrew cuomo for months during
his coveted news conferences resigned
late on sunday according to the ap on
the heels of a report that found cuomo
sexually harassed 11 women leaving the
governor without his top 8 as he faces
the prospect of impeachment derosa who
had been one of cuomo's most fierce
defenders and strategists said in a
statement sent to multiple news
organizations serving the people of new
york had quote the greatest honor of my
life she added quote personally the past
few years have been emotionally and
mentally trying she didn't give a more
specific reason for her resignation she
said i'm forever grateful for the
opportunity to have worked with such
talented and committed colleagues on
behalf of our state
scores of democrats including president
biden have urged cuomo to leave office
or face an impeachment battle he
probably cannot win about two-thirds of
the state assembly have already said
they favor an impeachment trial if he
refuses nearly all 63 members of the
state senate have called for cuomo to
step down or be removed more punishing
news for the governor is expected on
monday when an assembly committee meets
to discuss possible impeachment
proceedings and cbs this morning is
scheduled to broadcast the first tv
interview from an executive assistant
who accused cuomo of groping her breast
in her first public interview in which
she identified herself brittany kamisso
told cbs and the times union newspaper
of albany what cuomo did was a crime and
that he needs to be held accountable she
said cuomo reached under her shirt and
fondled her when they were alone in a
room at the executive mansion last year
and on another occasion robbed her rear
end while they posed for a photo she was
the first woman to file a criminal
complaint against cuomo by the way i'll
speak to a quick twitter friend here so
over the weekend i trended a little bit
on twitter because there's a series of
photos of me at the last young americas
foundation event uh taking a series of
pictures and when when there's a woman
in the picture with me my hand which is
sort of like around
the the person i'm taking a picture with
is out to the side so you can see my
free hand
and the reason for this
is what we will call the keanu reeve
rule right which is keep the hands off
and visibly away right for a very very
good reason this would be that reason in
any case it appears that andrew cuomo
has a problem for himself he may not be
the only one who has a problem it turns
out chris cuomo may have a problem as
well
so it turns out that chris now says that
he is taking a vacation there's only one
problem he apparently took a vacation
like two weeks ago
so according to mediaite chris cuomo is
set to begin a week-long vacation from
his prime time cnn talk show on friday a
break the host described as a previously
scheduled absence planned around his
birthday he said every year i take my
birthday week off i'm looking forward to
it again the only problem here is that
he just took a little bit of time off
like a couple of weeks ago
well this prompted brian stelter to try
to explain how cnn was handling the
chris cuomo of it all and completely
failing here is brian stelter on
reliable sources failing to explain why
his own network allowed chris to cover
his brother for months on end and then
chris to ignore the fact that his
brother is about to get impeached in the
state of new york
this has been a conundrum for cnn that
has no perfect answer no perfect
solution well it does some think cnn
made it worse by letting chris interview
his brother when covenant team was
ravaging new york but that was an
unprecedented time period and so is this
one a famous family in the news a
governor who soared to the highest
heights last year now falling to the
lowest lows
self-inflicted wounds
and a brother who just wants to do his
job just wants to anchor his show
but can he
that's the key question who j wait chris
just wants to do his job in anchorage
that's just what he wants to do
weird because it seemed like he wanted
to do like a smothers brother's routine
with his with his brother i love brian
brian's shelter man reliable sources
it's a conundrum with no perfect it's a
riddle wrapped in a mystery wrapped in
an enigma wrapped in a conundrum
it's like four different mysteries
wrapped in one another
intertwined inextricably or
it's a conundrum that ends with chris
cuomo getting fired
possible
cnn's never going to do that and you all
know it we all know that that's not how
any of this works already meanwhile the
worst story of the weekend comes out of
chicago again nobody seems to care about
cops who get killed
every day on the job all over the united
states this is why it is it is really
galling when you hear the democrats in
dc
pretend that they care deeply about the
police officers who are assaulted on
january 6. when i say pretend what i
mean is that they probably care about
those specific police officers but they
don't seem to demand very much about the
other police officers all over the
united states who are harmed literally
every day in the line of fire you know
how many police officers were injured
like literally hundreds of police
officers maybe thousands of police
officers injured last year during the
black lives matter riots did democrats
have anything to say about any of that
not a word not a word january 6 they're
all up
they're all about because obviously when
police officers are injured by people
who are right-wing then that is worth
noting
again if you're only situationally
against violence against cops this means
you're not actually against violence
against cops it's the same thing i say
about anti-semitism or racism if you're
only situationally against it you're
really not against it if if
anti-semitism only bothers you
when it's somebody who you politically
disagree doing the anti-semitism you
don't care about anti-semitism if you're
a democrat you're like i love rasheeda
to lebanon but man that marjorie taylor
green is just the worst when it comes to
the jews you don't care about
anti-semitism you're just a liar and
when you say i care deeply about the
police officers who are hurt on january
6th
but i don't care at all like i have
nothing to say about the police officers
hurt every day on the job and in fact i
will just continue to call police
officers systemically racist and
increase the risk to them by
alienating entire groups of americans
from the cops and
uh mollycoddle people who call for
defund the police i have a tough time
believing that you care deeply about
violence against the police on a root
level in any case in chicago chicago
tribune reports one chicago police
officer was murdered another was
critically wounded during an exchange of
gunfire with at least one suspect during
a traffic stop saturday night in the
west englewood neighborhood on the south
side police family and the cook county
medical examiner's office identified the
officer who died as ella french a 29
year old who had worked as a chicago cop
since april 2018.
she was the first chicago police officer
to be shot and killed in the line of
duty since mayor lori lightfoot took
office in 2019 the other officer with
the department since august 2014 is
fighting for his life in critical
condition at the university of chicago
medical center andrew french said his
younger sister always thought of herself
before others he said my sister's always
been a person of integrity she's always
done the right thing even when nobody's
looking she always believed in people
and believed in doing the right thing
she's always believed in taking care of
people they can't take care of
themselves andrew french an iraq war
veteran said that even before she joined
the force his sister was a proponent of
therapy or social services over jail
time he said she wanted to see people
get the help they needed more than just
throwing people in jail he said she was
a humanitarian she believes in human
rights she was one of the officers on
the force they thought that thought they
needed reform because she's seen the
front line like i have she's always been
a very caring person when i was in iraq
me and her we talked she has some
attributes you don't find in the world
anymore
and she was killed
just after 9 pm saturday near west 63rd
and south bell avenue when the officers
conducted a traffic stop on three people
in a vehicle now i've been reliably
informed the traffic stops are basically
not problematic right that when police
approach people during a traffic stop
they should maybe be unarmed you know
some social workers should show up
during the stop someone opened fire on
the officers at least one officer
returned fire two officers including
french and one of the suspects were shot
the officers were taken to ufc medical
center the wounded suspect was taken to
advocate christ medical center in
oaklawn
he and one other male suspect were in
custody a female suspect at large after
the shooting was arrested later on
sunday
so just a terrible horrifying story
lightfoot lamented the pro law
enforcement world's complaints that
society doesn't do enough for cops who
feel there are roadblocks to doing their
jobs effectively she also lamented
critics of the police who have long
denounced officers treatment of
neighborhoods of color stop just stop
this constant strife is not what we need
in the moment the police are not our
enemies she said they're human just as
we are we have a common enemy it's the
guns and the gangs eradicating both is
complex we cannot let the size of the
challenge deter us we have to continue
striking hard blows every day well you
know it's a good way to do that not
undermining the cops that is a major
issue it will continue to be a major
issue and it does get cops killed i know
enough cops on forces all over the
united states to know what their
experience day to day is like and how
politicians make it worse for political
gain lori lightfoot is one of those
politicians
alrighty coming up we have another hour
of the ben shapiro show a little bit
later today
also coming up soon the matt walsh airs
1 30 pm eastern be sure to check it out
over at dailywire.com i'm ben shapiro
this is the bench bureau show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliott feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pavel
wydowsky associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciovitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica kranz the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
john bickley here daily wire
editor-in-chief wake up every morning
with our new show morning wire on
today's episode the taliban surges
across afghanistan apple plans to scan
people's cell phones for evidence of
child sexual abuse and schools reopen
amid more covet concerns join us and get
the facts first on the news you need to
know with our show morning wire